[Music]
let's say you want to build an app not
just any app but a server less scalable
mobile syncing analytical IOT app if you
do a quick Google search you will get
one point two billion results on how to
do this so where do you start my name is
natalie vase and i'm a product manager
on cloud firestore today I want to talk
to you about building amazing apps
specifically how to build globally
scalable apps with cloud firestore if
you're starting a new project from
scratch and you want to build it
yourself
you'll likely have to think about a
couple of things number one setting up a
database number two creating some kind
of API layer on top of it so you can
make queries from your clients and that
probably means third creating an
authentication service to make sure
users can only access data they're
supposed to and then lastly making sure
your data syncs with your local results
which are probably being stored in a
completely separate client database now
just make sure it works across multiple
platforms it can easily handle things
like spotty network connections simple
right as soon as your app goes viral
fingers crossed for you all of a sudden
you have to worry about scaling high
availability and disaster recovery
strategies and you'll probably need to
hire more people to manage it too or you
can just use cloud firestore cloud
firestore is a fully managed server
'less no sequel document database
purpose-built for solving some of the
toughest problems of mobile web and iot
op development today in many ways it's
more than a database it's an entire
back-end for your apps to create
firestore we learned from two other
popular databases at Google
firebase real time database and cloud
datastore usage patterns have shifted
since those architectures were designed
some seven to ten years ago respectively
so we took a close look at the developer
wish list for each of these to inform
the product you can think of firestore
as the best of both of these worlds
cloud fire store handles all the things
that you don't want to think about when
you're developing a mobile app so you
can really focus on your core business
the
first thing to know is that cloud
firestore is fully supported in the
firebase SDKs this includes web iOS and
Android so you can access data directly
from these clients this works in
conjunction with firebase auth and
security rules and those things allow
you to control who has access to read
and modify data on the server there's
that off layer we mentioned at the
beginning you wouldn't believe how
normal it has become for people to look
at their apps when there is absolutely
no chance of connectivity a person
checks their phone an average of 80
times in a day so it's becoming
increasingly common for people to expect
our apps to work offline and across
devices with cloud firestore the client
libraries already come with full support
for offline mode the sdk handles
conflict resolution on device and syncs
up with the server when you reconnect
because we built cloud firestore with
the serverless architecture you don't
have to worry about provisioning
capacity planning scaling or maintenance
there are servers distributed across the
world just not ones that you have to
manage all of this is taken care of by
the system scaling is automatic and
happens as an online operation say
goodbye to maintenance windows on top of
that cloud fire store is built for the
cloud that means it's replicated across
zones and regions depending on how you
choose to configure it and this year
alone and as part of going generally
available we added 10 new locations to
cloud fire store replication across data
centers is really one of those things
you want to outsource if you can it
becomes complicated quickly and is a
huge overhead for ops teams with this
replication you get five nines SLA for
multi region and a four nines SLA for
regional deployments this is one of the
highest availability services we offer
all of this lets you focus on your core
business and leave the infrastructure to
Google Cloud which is our core business
with over 1 million databases created
already cloud firestore has seen a huge
diversity of workloads are you deployed
within our customer base the unifying
themes among these workloads include
number one the need for data access even
when connectivity lapses number two
scalability for many users across
platforms and number three the ability
to move quickly from prototype to
production and that's cloud firestore
your Auto syncing auto scaling database
in the cloud give it a try and find out
why it's the most discussed cloud
database on stack overflow
[Music]
you